my name is John Thomas and I'm the
bureau chief of South Asia for Reuters
based in New Delhi I've just moderated a
panel on India policy and outlook for
India policy and the implications for
policy of the political outlook as we
head into the very crucial elections in
the state of utter pradesh next year and
the national elections in 2014 it does
seem from what the panelists were saying
that there is a crisis of credibility in
Indian politicians in the Indian
political system and I think we saw that
with the with the numbers of people that
came out in the streets in support of
Anna Hazare in the middle of this year
because of the outrage and there was
over corruption very big corruption in
the heart of government and also kind of
in industry and so with this crisis of
confidence in government you have got a
situation where the Congress party
leading the government right now is in a
kind of paralysis we're seeing very
little progress on reform in fact this
has been a case for quite a long time
since 2004 since the party took power we
actually haven't seen one real reform
that is open the Indian economy that's
seven years it's a very long time and
now you have a party which is very much
on the back foot very very difficult
we've got a winter session of Parliament
coming up but it's going to be very
different for them to deliver serious
far-reaching reform is going to make a
difference at a time when you have the
economy slowing down we've got a quite a
mark slowdown in economic growth in
India we're starting to see some
problems of debt and merging
particularly among the banks and we're
starting to see consumption going more
slowly and you know this is at a time
when you starting to see a serious
economic problems in euros
on and the United States so the need is
very critical right now to get reforms
moving to get policy moving and to get
legislative to get legislation through
Parliament and I think one of the key
points of the panelists are making is
that we need to see some some reform of
the political and the parliamentary and
the party systems in India to ensure
that there is a delivery on legislation
a delivery that will really bring the
reforms that India needs to raise its
growth from that seven percent friend
that base friend to the nine ten percent
which will start to lift people out of
poverty